uh this lady called becky you ever seen
this this video
okay yeah this is it right here i don't
know if you want to fast-forward and you
see this lady
yeah there she is
and
she's
yeah footage
actually happens in an exorcism
i would do things
her name she was possessed by demons she
firmly believes yeah so she firmly
believes now it turns out
she was severely abused as a child that
she had major drug issues she's had a
rough life she was a prostitute and she
was a member of a cult how convenient
so you add all that up and next thing
you know she's possessed by demons so
it's this is i guess to
the point that we're kind of making is
like
99 of people that think they're
possessed by demons turns out it's not
the case that they have major major
major issues going on with their body
something like this doesn't exactly help
the cause to believe that there are
demons it just sort of proves the point
that no there's just some messed up
people out there
and i don't know what they're dealing
with do the presence of all those things
negate that perhaps it was a spiritual
issue
or yes i i that's what i'm saying
it negates it for you
well
i mean
tough life abused drugs i agree
prostitute and a member of a cult i
agree yeah that's not exactly the great
resume that you're going to believe that
person i would look in there that
and say
okay maybe this was sensationalized
right maybe maybe she wasn't
but on the other hand you say could it
be that the drugs the abuse and the
other things
and then the cult is what gave
the ground or the foothold
to demonic activity i don't know the
answer to it and by the way it sure
sounds fishy it does so i'm with you on
that on perception but it's also
those are avenues that could open up a
place where this person could have
legitimately had have you seen things
like this i've seen things like that
but again early life and some traumas
and other things that led to
ultimately a stronghold
yeah i'm thinking of a
a person that i was interviewing who
believed that she was possessed
and she had shared with me that growing
up in mexico at the age of seven her
father began to rape her
so her father raped her from the time
she was seven until she was twelve
and then when she turned twelve her
father she said turned his attention
to her younger sister oh boy so she said
she was
broken blame god for allowing this to
happen
in her tradition she turned to
corinderos and brujas
you know witch doctors and witches who
said they could help put the pieces of
her life back together
but though that
example of abuse led her down the
pathway
into the world of the occult so she's
telling me this story and she's with a
friend of hers there's me and there's
another priest
and then she's looked at me and she's
crying uncontrollably and she looks at
me and says
will you help me and i say to her
jesus is the one who can help you and
when i said that her eyeballs turned
green
her pupils became slanted like a serpent
and this voice comes out of her mouth
and says who's he he has no power over
us
so was she possessed by a demon you
believe
so then again i had her go through steps
to see a psychiatrist and whatnot and
then i did make the decision to pray
with her
and when i made the decision to pray
with her
so we are in a chapel we're praying
and as soon as i begin praying
there's the the demon manifests again
there's the green eyeballs
and the demon looks at me and says
you can't get rid of us we've been here
for too long and you're just not strong
enough
yeah but you're talking about a person
who was raped by her father
okay i mean if you want to talk about a
messed up person
how messed up can you get than that and
not only that then he's about to take on
the younger sister after you're 12. so i
don't know i'm i'm not a doctor or
anything like that but like if you want
a prescription for someone who's going
to have a messed up life boom there you
go
so but how do you just how do you
describe the what i witnessed then the
the witnesses are different these are
two different i hear you but it's not
like she was just a normal girl and had
a nice life and just you know every
happy-go-lucky girl and then all of a
sudden the devil pops up because i'm
talking about some of the most
disgusting acts a human can do to
another human is what happened to her
and i hear these stories all the time
that's why i don't just run into the
room
you know with my right of exorcism book
and say here i'm to save the day no
to me there's no such thing as an
emergency exorcism when those things are
done
is when problems really unfold
arriving at doing an exorcism should be
at the end not at the beginning so like
this what we just witnessed did somebody
just walk in and say hey i i need this
exorcism i have people that tell me all
the time i need to come and have an
exorcism today
but to me i would begin by understanding
where the person has been knowing their
history were they traumatized had they
been working with the council or i even
tell people it isn't just a one angle
approach
perhaps you do need to have some
deep in spirituality but that doesn't
mean you need an exorcism maybe you need
to breathe so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]